hey guys and welcome to episode 5 of
grizzly Valley despite my very broad
claims in the last part that I would
actually finish this Main Street in two
parts I didn't quite make it it's going
to be three videos but it's going to
take three videos to completely finish
it including nearly all details and even
some backstage areas and some areas
around the main streets and basically in
this episode I want to focus on getting
some new buildings in and finishing the
majority of the other side of the Main
Street as well and in the next episode
I'll try to get some backstage areas in
as well as finish some of the unfinished
buildings and add one extra building
which actually really like in the end
but that's all for next time and this
time though one of the first things
which I really wanted to do was to
finish this building over here or at
least at a building over here because I
just wanted to quickly finish this
corner and make the entire Main Street
building on this side like an actual
finished single building and what's
interesting about this is that much like
the last episode and the next episode I
really wanted to have a different style
for each individual building not just
because it's good from a mainstream
perspective but also because it's a lot
of fun and also good practice and nice
to find some ways to make different
things with the different scenery
objects and what was actually
interesting about this building is that
it was my first try I think to actually
turn your windows upside down and
looking back at it I'm actually really
happy with how it turned out the main
idea behind it was really that the
windows that the game comes with are
really good but they are very much
narrow and they're really themed to the
spanish-colonial pirate idea and I
wanted to have some more wide issue
windows but also windows that don't have
the pediments and details that the
windows in the game come with because
they have their little pediments like
the small round decorative decorations
which they have on top of the window
where I really felt like sometimes I
just want to have straight windows
without the pediments on top of it so
the idea was there to just flip them
upside down have the pediments at the
bottom put a balcony to cover up the
pediment and actually have more square
windows which in the end I am actually
pretty happy with how it turned out and
I'll definitely use that a
more in future episodes as well choose
to make sure that there is a lot more
variety in the windows then or at least
there's more seeming variety in the
window standing what we actually have
because there are just a couple of
windows at the moment but I want to try
to make it seem like I'm used many
different windows in all of the
different buildings and now these
buildings over here are sort of more
Parisian they're much more European than
really the more American Victorian
buildings in the rest of my streets but
they are still somewhat Victorian and
for me at least they really remind me of
the more symmetrical architecture that
you see in Paris or Bucharest it's it
takes influences from that so it's not
entirely the same and definitely on a
much smaller scale in this case but I
just wanted to try to have this kind of
building it's also not the most
realistic in terms of this being a theme
park but it's really just something
which I also wanted to experiment with
which is in the end of course also the
core of this park and largely the ego of
this main street so far as well and one
of the things in which I think these
buildings were actually a nice
experiment is to mess a little bit more
with the different layers of buildings
so for these buildings in particular I
wanted to use separate buildings on
these arches just to make sure that the
arches could stick out a little bit from
the rest of the building not too much
but enough so that they seemed part of
the building but still add extra detail
to it and yeah you really see the
details pop out a bit and of course
because if I just put them into the
walls I would have z-fighting which I
really wanted to not have because
fighting textures is one of my least
favorite things to look at and the same
probably goes for everyone so yeah that
was one thing and also wanted to try
some separate buildings just for the
pillars so that I'd be able to use very
narrow pillars and sink them into the
building a lot to not use pillars but be
able to use pilasters which is pretty
much the war version of pillars which I
wanted to try just by sinking these
pillars into the buildings and of course
I'm completely addicted to
the little balconies in to make Bella
straights and they've really fit this
theme and actually surprisingly good for
a classical type architecture and I
really think they fit pretty well with
the roofs which is a roof type which I
haven't really tried yet which is what
you see more in Paris like a mental type
roof which is round a little bit less
steep than the other roof so it doesn't
stick out as much and it's really just a
much smaller roof with some dormers on
it and it's something which I didn't
have yet so really wanted to try it and
this seemed like the best building to do
it with since it really isn't the same
thing and another thing which I wanted
to try here a little bit more which
we've also done in some previous
buildings is to make the windows a
little bit wider like as I said I really
do love the windows which the game comes
with but they're very narrow and very
much just for that colonial Spanish
pirate style and the fact that they're
so narrow doesn't really work out for if
you want to have short buildings or you
just happen to have buildings where you
want to have some wider windows and it's
also a really good way to make a
building have more detail on general so
I wanted to try to just combine double
windows where I could to try to turn
them into one window just by having
these little details like using this
ball piece as a a small window
supporting structure or using some other
windows behind windows to make a little
special pediments basically try to
combine pieces to make it seem like the
double windows are actually single
windows by having that sort of central
accent to them and I'm also completely
addicted to these chimneys as dormers
which I think also quite nicely fifty
style of these buildings they're
definitely not quite finished yet and I
will finish them eventually some time
off screen because I didn't record
everything for this episode again I
added some foliage and minor details
when I was just working off-screen but
this is more or less the general juh
yeah and the general gist of what
everything is gonna be
and on this side it just wanted to have
a rather simple building really just
filler and to make sure that this entire
section is more or less part of the main
streets as well and isn't just random
forest but it's really a filler building
in the sense that it's sort of made to
not distract too much from the
symmetrical buildings which I belong
inside the path since they are really
the main focus of this plaza especially
given how quite large and detailed and
symmetrical they are and I also wanted
to take a little sidestep I sort of just
drifted all over the place at this point
in the time lapse and I was like well
I'm gonna do this no I'm gonna do this
and that's why it turned out little bit
messy in the end so I'm sorry about that
but I tried to get some different fences
in there I think looking back at this I
sort of liked the idea of using the
white walls for small borders and
combining them with different pieces but
they are so awfully White's that even
though they look really good on their
own and if you combine them with other
things as well they don't really work
through well for borders like this I
think so in the future might just want
to use the wooden borders of stone
borders and leave it at that because
this seems a little bit too white for
just fences so may want to get back to
that but I was really just randomly
experimenting with that at this point
because I just sort of felt like doing
so and for the rest of this area also
really quickly added some foliage as
well just to make it look a little bit
finished but that said I actually have
no idea yet what I'm going to do with
this helix and it really feels like a
helix why I should put something in the
middle
especially given - given how close it is
to the park entrance and that this area
in general is quite densely themed and
really one of the first things which you
see in the park so it really feels like
I should do something with it but I have
no clue yet whatever or I have no clue
yet what I'm gonna add in there so if
anybody does have some awesome ideas for
that then don't you don't feel free to
shoot feel free to shoot them I might
just use them I never I can never really
promise that I'll take any type of
recommendation but sometimes it's good
to get some ideas which I
going to come up with myself so might
always want to get to it I've been
thinking I want to add something to that
helix in any case now back to the main
street though and away from my little
off-topic adventure there I wanted to
add a building on this side of the Main
Street which almost mirrors the building
on the other side but it's in a sense
that they are visually similar but all
of the little details are different so
for this building I didn't want to use
the second floor with the sort of
beige-ish color but I wanted to use the
word over here and I also changed some
of the details up to just be a bit
different so while they're very similar
or nearly identical in terms of how
their overall laid out all of the
details are going to be quite different
and that's really the idea behind it to
create an ensemble as they would call it
of buildings that fit together but
aren't quite exactly the same which is
the general idea over Main streets
anyway it's so yeah there isn't too much
unique about this but yeah like I said
like the other building has the sort of
modern sci-fi ish fences on the second
floor balcony this one is going to have
the more classical balustrade on the
second floor and where the other
building didn't have any details on the
windows like using some different pieces
to create different patterns on the
windows this one will have a bit of that
but then again there are some
similarities as well I wanted to keep
both towers white because those are
really the main focus points of the
buildings and wanted to keep the general
style of the tower the same so I really
wanted to go with the same cornerstones
as well and I can't stop placing those
cornerstones those are one of my
favorite thing so far they work out
surprisingly well but yeah this piece
actually which I forgot to talk about in
the last episode but there's that
balcony piece it's one of the two
concrete balconies like there is the
balcony which I'm using as a balustrade
over here but there's also the balcony
which doesn't actually have a balustrade
around it but it's just one flat mat
concrete piece with some supports
underneath it but those stone supports
have some really beautiful
detail on them and really cool textures
at least and that's what I really like
using them pretty much everywhere to add
small details to whatever I can really
add it to is another example by the way
of like the upside down windows which I
kind of like as well but yeah it's that
it's that sort of freeze ish Penniman
ish balcony which I really like using
because if you rotate it and get rid of
the rest of the balcony and sort of just
sink the texture into the wall you can
really use it to add extra details to
windows and things like that which is
actually a lot of fun to do as well so
yeah this is the general building I do
have to say because of that wooden
texture it almost sort of looks like a
western building which is well I would
say it's necessarily because of the
wooden texture but it's really because
of the color of the wood mostly because
something which I would have liked to do
more looking back at this is to simulate
the wood that you very often see on Main
streets like Main Street really have
these horizontal beams of wood that make
up the walls where all of the different
buildings have different paints colors
on those wooden beams but they still
often have these horizontal wooden beams
for the walls and that is something
which I would really love to use over
here but just doesn't really exist and
at some point I did try off screen to
see if you can actually combine the
different flat roof pieces and stack
them to make a ball which is somewhat
possible but it's not really that handy
because you don't have ridges in between
the roofs which I had hoped for
so it doesn't really get the effect of
the wooden walls which I had hoped to
get but there is actually a way to get
that but that is something which I'm
going to show in the next episode
actually so no I'm not gonna leave
people hanging on that but that's gonna
be something which I'll return to in the
next episode but if you take those
concrete beams you can actually sink
them into the wall
in such a way that there's only one
concrete beam left and if you stack them
all on the exact height of a wall you
can actually make a greyish wooden
texture but it's a it's it's not really
the most well best
thing to do time wise because it takes
quite a while to stack all of those
concrete beams to make anymore wooden
texture but yeah that was the idea
anyway I'm massively behind the time
house at this point I wanted to have a
quick building which was actually I
think inspired by a building in the main
street of Hong Kong none of these
buildings are directly inspired by any
buildings on Main streets they're all
sort of just following the general style
but that's beige-ish building with the
balustrade sticking out at the top was
quite directly inspired by a building
which i think is in the main street of
disneyland hong kong but I'm not
entirely sure on that and then I wanted
to have a very quick really small one
tile building in between that's just to
make sure that I had enough space left
to make this double building over here
but didn't quite have to leave a gap in
between there and sometimes you really
do have these very cute narrow houses in
the middle of Main streets and that's
something which I didn't have yet so
figured well I might as well add that as
well and then this building over here is
or at least I should say there are two
separate buildings they're very similar
and sort of interconnected but I just
wanted to use different textures because
one very white building is quite
uncommon in main streets it's much more
like many different narrow buildings so
that's why I wanted to have in here as
well so really figured well if I can
replace this texture on this building
it's probably going to look like a
different building and sort of just went
from there I'm not actually gonna do
anything with any of these buildings
though which is something that I do get
some comments about and I'll have to
address that just because it is probably
a little bit unorthodox to not do
anything with these buildings it's
basically because for some of these
buildings are really close to the path
and I can't exactly connect them to the
path with shops because they're just too
close either too close or too far away
from it and for many of these buildings
where I want to have these patios or you
see the roof either the wooden roof so
the concrete roof sort of sticking out
of that I wish I could make them into
actual functional buildings and put a
restaurant inside of them but if I were
late paths to the
the guests were just completely clipped
through the past year with their feeds
which is something which doesn't really
look too good though looking back at
that some of the guests are currently
walking through walls which isn't too
great either so I might one is still do
it in the future but I don't think so
not much of a chance that I'm actually
gonna make this part of your building
over here actually functional that said
though I think that very narrow one tile
blue building might actually be good for
a restaurant at some point in the future
so may want to get back to that and the
rest of this building is really quite
similar to what I already have and I
also still had some shots which I
recorded as almost the flying camera
though these aren't quite as good I do
have to say by the way I recorded these
shots not with any speak not any
spectacular camera function or something
that other people don't have I just sort
of hooked that I just sort of changed
the camera settings the key settings of
the camera to minus 10 when it comes to
the movement and then started spamming
the a and D keys on my keyboard which
was a absolute pain but it actually did
result in some really cool videos though
they are slightly sped up because yeah
lag is still a bit of an issue for me
and it's definitely parts of the fact
that this park is pretty large the game
is of course they want alpha as well and
I don't have the very best computer but
it's one reason why I am a little bit
hesitant to try more life or real-time
parts and here you can also kind of see
it jittering a bit but that is
completely my mistake and in very I was
really good at tapping the keyboard at
this point in time but yeah this is
pretty much what the Main Street looks
like and more of a battery close-up of
what each individual building is
actually like I kind of like it so far
but there is still quite a lot to be
worked on especially a new building
which might actually be my favorite
building of the Main Street so far and
also adding some extra details and
actually doing a bit of backstage area
to make everything look a little bit
realistic but yeah that's all for the
next episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys next time